95% of our behavior is coming from sub
below Consciousness are you living the
life you want or are you living the life
you've been programmed and the answer
unfortunately is most of us are living
the life we've been programmed and and
the programming comes from other people
so it's not our lives the brain is a
computer most powerful computer that
humans have ever experienced but it has
parallels to computers and number one is
this when you would buy a computer
before they put the programs in you
could bring it home brand new computer
screens on and I said do something and
people well no I can't do anything first
you have to put programs into a computer
but there are no programs so the first
seven years of a child's life is the
brain is not operating at the higher
level of Consciousness hey it's EV
Carmichael and I watch these videos
every day because I need them for
motivation being around successful
entrepreneurs every morning helps me
believe that I can do great things too
it's like your morning coffee but for
your goals kickstarting your day with a
blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
hash believe in the comments below so I
can celebrate with
you so today let's get some incredible
motivation from the one and only Bruce
Lipton enjoy a child up through seven is
not operating at Consciousness except
for a little bit it's primarily
operating at a lower vibration called
Theta and I said well what is Theta I
say is expressed as imagination so
that's how uh children can have a tea
party and they pour nothing into the cup
and then they drink the nothing and then
they explain how that was the best tea
they ever had or a child rides a broom
saying it's a horse in the child's mind
that is not a broom it's a it's a horse
but it's mixing imagination and reality
but Theta is hypnosis and the
significance of that is children have to
learn how to become a member of a family
the rules member of a Community the
rules I go how how can an infant a young
kid learn these rules they can't go to
school they can't read the book and all
that and I say you don't have to Nature
provided Theta hypnosis so that they can
observe the parents the family and the
community just observe their behavior
and download those as programs age seven
then that's when they start to become
more conscious and engaging themselves
first seven years is programming but
after age 795 % of your life is coming
from that program so if you can program
the child for the first seven years and
the rest of the life of that child is
actually an expression of that program
positive thinking can heal you of any
disease negative thinking can create any
disease it can even kill you you believe
you're going to die you're that's the
belief and I say so belief the picture
is translate into chemistry brain and
the chemistry via the blood goes to the
cells and controls genetics and behavior
so your thoughts are the primary control
of your genes and I go significance just
simple conclusion the old story what is
called genetic determinism genes
determine the character of your life
that's what most people learn is is no
longer valid uh it is now recognized uh
that the genes are receptive to the
signal that you send them and all of a
sudden I say well then your thoughts are
over writing your jeans I go yes I do
and then I conclusion which Mark has
been talking about for years is well
then you better start thinking healthy
thoughts because it's the negative
thoughts that put the chemistry in that
that will create any disease uh and all
of a sudden it goes positive thinking
negative thinking but it's all connected
to belief 5% of the day we move toward
wishes desires what we want even you
know the addict is like yeah I don't
want this this is not my life I really
want this and and all that
and then I say yeah but that only works
5% of the day 95% of the day you're
coming from The Habit yeah but the Habit
was other people's behavior that you put
into the subconscious first and so 95%
of the day you're not operating from
your wishes and desires you're operating
from a program sure okay but now here's
the catch and then we'll get we'll get
on to it and that is this by definition
if I am thinking all of a sudden I say
what am I doing next Wednesday I go into
my head and I'm thinking about what I'm
doing what's on state by definition I'm
not paying attention to what's going on
so that doesn't mean like you're walking
down the street you have a thought and
then you freeze while the thought
happens and then after the thought then
you start walking back down the street
again no if you're walking down the
street and you have a thought the moment
you have a conscious mind engaged in
thought it the functions are defaulted
to the subconscious program so in other
words I know how to walk that's a habit
I learned that so I don't need my
conscious mind to tell me how to walk so
my conscious mind goes in thought I'm
still walking so whatever behavior I'm
doing driving a car I I don't have to
pay attention to what's going on when
I'm driving a car I mean the the joke
when I lecture about is I say look you
know I've been in a car with a passenger
we get so engaged in a conversation my
conscious mind is tied up with the
conversation and then all of a sudden I
look out the window of the car and it
Dawns on me I haven't paid attention on
the road for the last five minutes how
did I get home yeah and and here's what
the Nee part is well look Drive is once
you practice and learn how to drive
practice makes habit habit means that
the subconscious mind doesn't need you
to explain how to drive and what to
watch out for subconscious mind's
already got a program 90% of health
issues on this planet 90% is probably
more is due to stress what does that
mean I say that the chemistry of stress
in the
blood negatively impacts the body
originally just uh make a difference why
would the body have a problem with you
know dealing with the stress because I
said when the body is evolving what
stress did we actually have I give
example a sabertooth tiger is chasing us
I said that's that's a moment of stress
folks and I said what happens the stress
hormones go into the body and they
prepare you for running fight or flight
then you get away from that tiger and
guess
what no more stress so how long did that
take 10 15 minutes okay I go so when we
had in our history and in our Evolution
it was only for a very short period of
time just temporarily get the body ready
for fight or flight just temporary but
today stress is every day 24 hours a day
365 days a year all of us are under
stress do you have enough money will you
be able to get health care will you be
able to pay the rent my God this stress
all the time this is why we have a
health care
crisis okay and I say why the chemistry
of stress and I'll explain it in three
steps this is the result of stress so
you understand where the problem comes
from when you're in fight or flight your
mission is to run away from the
saber-tooth tiger and I go so what does
that mean I say well you need all the
energy in your body to run away from the
tiger and I said well what systems do I
need to run away from the tiger I say
well mainly your arms and legs because
that's going to carry you away I say
okay and I say so why is that important
I said because that's where you need the
blood why the blood is the energy to
make those arms and legs move so the
more blood you have in the muscles uh in
the arms and legs the more powerful you
are to run away from the the problem
okay so I go so where was the blood if
there was no stress and I go oh what
else is in the body take the arms and
legs off the body what do you got left
you've got the gut the viscera you got
theut guts and I say well what do they
do I say oh they maintain the body they
clean it filter it put nutrients into it
remove waste products replace the cells
that are damaged blah blah blah I go oh
so the gut is where all the maintenance
of my body is being taken care of and I
go yes now here's the point you're being
chased by a saber-tooth tiger you think
you need to do all the work on the body
right now maybe you could just like have
an air raid siren or something say look
stop work we're going we're going to run
I say well what happens and here's what
it is the stress hormones cause the
blood vessels in the gut to constrict
tight I go what does that mean it pushes
the blood from the gut to the arms and
legs that's the one I need to run with
yeah but what does it mean about the gut
and I say it stops
functioning maintenance of the body is
out taking care of the system is out why
the energy is getting ready to run so
you moment the stress hormones are in
you stop maintaining the body number two
and this is the big one you ready stress
hormones shut off the immune system oh
yeah I say why is that important well if
you've ever been sick you might have
known maybe you didn't even have the
energy to get out of bed when the immune
system is operating like that it uses so
much energy you probably can't even move
sometimes I go yep so I say you're being
chased by a saber-tooth tiger you have a
bacterial
infection how do you want to split the
energy how much energy you want to fight
that bacteria back or how much energy
you want to run away from the tiger let
me help you with the answer you want all
the energy to run away from the tiger so
stress hormones listen to this stress
hormones shut off the immune system to
conserve energy to escape the stress
oh my God that means the more stressed
you're under the less effective your
immune system is because his stress
hormones are shutting it
down I said there were three things and
the third one is also very important
when you're in a fight or flight it's
not time to think and I say what does
that mean I say well thinking is a very
slow process I ask you to think about
something you go oh I go when you're
running away from the tiger you don't
have to go you don't have time for that
you got to run so stress hormones shut
off thinking hi I'm Bruce Lon author of
the bestselling books the biology belief
spontaneous Evolution and the honeymoon
effect I'm here to thank Evan carmichel
for featuring me on his YouTube channel
and I want to let you know that Evan is
giving away links where you can watch
the First episodes of my special Gaia
series entitled in a revolution for free
Evan is making this offer to thank you
for watching this video you will find
the links in the description section
below thank you reprogramming my
subconscious mind to do what get rid of
or replace the disempowering programs
with empowering ones and I go here's the
benefit here's the benefit of it once
the new program is in you don't have to
even make any effort why you haven't
made any effort to get where you are
right
now it's your subconscious been doing
all the time so I said well what if you
put only good stuff in your subconscious
I go well then without any effort you
will have all the good things that you
were looking for health and happiness
and relationships and stuff like that
and that's the
destination because you got to get out
of I'm a victim everyone thinks they're
a victim I go well what does victim mean
powerless and so if I'm I'm telling you
I'm powerless and what do you think is
going to happen and as you went like
that before the answer is this I'll sell
you some power I'll be the
pharmaceutical you want some power I'll
sell you this drug okay I'm this guy
I'll sell tell you that you'll get more
power more power what did they do they
made us into consumers why I can't do it
I'm the victim but they can get it for
me how much do I pay them I say well hey
religion was based on all this stuff
yeah how how much does it cost me not to
go to hell well 10% of your salary was
tithing I go for what they're going to
protect me from going to hell uh you
know the the spiritual people I go why
am I paying
10% I can I could create my own Heaven
which I did and all of a sudden it says
stop disempowering me that is the
message who does it go to it goes to the
medical community that you disempower me
by telling me what my future is going to
be and I buy into the belief in that
first seven years that you control my
health I don't control my health I'd go
to the doctor the and my program is
doctor knows about my health I don't Z
the doctor says you're going to die in 3
months then guess what you just put in
your brain a program of in three months
I will be dead and you will I say will
you die of the cancer they said you had
and I go nope you can you die from the
belief of the three months because when
they started doing autopsies on people
that we know they were going to die in
three months of this cancer and they
start finding they didn't die from the
cancer where' they die from the belief
belief controls your life if you believe
you're going to die you can die just
from the belief humans are destroying
the environment because we're voracious
we eat everything out there take the
trees the plants the soil the we we take
everything voracious and we pushed it to
the situation now that the uh nature
can't support us because we we're
breaking the web of life down and it's
asking us to change and I say you know
let me give a parallel here that makes
sense uh and it's more than just a
parallel I think it's part of a fractal
consequence and that is this a
caterpillar is one of the most voracious
insects you've ever seen you put a
caterpillar on a plant like a monarch
butterfly and they on a milkweed plant
and you put that caterpillar on that
milkweed plant it eat every damn Leaf
off of that plant I mean and I've seen
it right here in in my yard there's a
plant and the caterpillars the mon love
that they put their caterpillars on
there I come back a couple days later
there's not one single leaf left on the
plant they ate all of the leaves and I
go then what I said well guess what they
reached the end and what do they do they
form what is called a pupa or
Chrysalis and then I say well what's
that well it's a cocoon I say then
what's happening in there I say it's a
miracle what's happening there I said
what's the consequence of that's
happening I say a caterpillar came in
and a butterfly goes out
I go wait what's the difference I say
the caterpillar is the most voracious
eating
everything and the Butterfly that comes
out is the lightest touch on the planet
floats in the air essentially doesn't
destroy anything and it lives and it and
it enjoys the beauty of it because it's
living in harmony I say why is it
relevant now let's go back to us I say
we're the caterpillar phase of human
civilization we're eating everything and
we push it against the wall now and
nature says that's it I said now what I
said well we have to go through a
metamorphosis I say why we need a
civilization that comes out on the other
side that's in Harmony and Health and
Living in the garden with cooperation
that's what def our destination is I go
well wait how do you go from caterpillar
to butterfly I go ah in that Chrysalis
that cocoon what was going on a
caterpillar came in and then what
started to break down and the cells
started to come apart and the community
started to come apart and the
caterpillar started to disappear and if
if you were a caterpillar cell you'd go
oh my God the caterpillar's dying and I
go what's happening it's disassembling
and I said then what's
happening certain cells called imaginal
cells become directors they say look
there's a new way to build here's a new
construction we're going to build this
butterfly so as cells are coming down
cells are also now moving in to build
the new one
okay so I said if you're in the middle
of this it looks like chaos it's like oh
my God the whole thing's falling apart
and I go yeah but guess what as it's
falling apart a new one is being built
we are in the Cocoon Pua stage at this
moment the caterpillar that we've been
is destructive anymore pushed it can't
do it what do we have to do we have to
transform I say how do you do that take
the structure of the caterpillar you
bring it down and you build up the
structure of the butterfly and I say but
they're happening at the same time well
that's the confusing part because then
you as a bystander in the middle can
look one way and go oh my God it's
falling apart and then you could look
the other way and go oh my god look what
they're building I say so where are we
well most people are oh my God it's
falling apart I go wrong place to put
your energy your vibration pull out of
that start to look like don't
participate because there's something
being built out here that's so much
better can is a program and you can
change cancer by changing a program but
if you believe the cancer is uh
genetically controlled which means you
have no control then you all of a sudden
say I'm a victim and then you want to
kill all the cancer cells because that's
the technology and I go the cancer cells
are not the problem they're the symptom
that's the result of a problem and so
you can kill all the damn cancer cells
you want but you never got to the cause
of the problem the cause of the problem
was something that caused a cell to
become cancer and all of a sudden we go
back to the Consciousness and the
programming and the same thing diabetes
type
two 100% environment 100%
environment and and I go so why this
important because as you've been talking
about let's get away from the idea that
I am a genetically programmed individual
no I'm a
Creator and I'm creating this and the
emphasis is how through the blood the
chemistry two parts
nutrition and
information and the idea about it is
this if you fail on the nutrition it's
like the machine will break down that's
what the function is if you don't take
care of the car it breaks down when you
look in the junkyard you see all the
cars piled up I say is that because they
were built wrong genetically incorrect I
go no no it was driver air error that
put those cars into the junkyard it's
driver error that's responsible for
99% of disease on this planet called
Rory mroy who uh he was leading the
Masters Golf Tournament a few years back
he had a big lead and you this is just
one example I'm not having to go at Rory
this is just is common in all sports
where um people almost self- implode and
for a few holes
like he could barely swing the golf club
what was really interesting is as I
always sort of reading a lot about it
trying to figure out what what's going
on here it's this conscious subconscious
again where he knows how to drive the
golf ball you know better than most
people on the planet yes so he's playing
usually from his subconscious the
patterns are in he knows how to shake
the ball right to left left to right
whatever but in that moment where it's
like oh man I'm leading the Masters
I need to be really careful now he's
trying to think you know well certainly
this is what people say I don't know
what was in his mind but you're almost
overthinking you're now trying to
control something that you could
naturally do as you say driving yeah if
you were thinking about when do I put
the clutch down or what timing is it
with the accelerator you know if you if
you drive a manual it's it's the same
kind of thing isn't it absolutely but
it's fact really when he's playing the
game he's playing it in the conscious
mind in the sense that he has a vision
I'm going to hit this ball and it's
going to go into that hole over there he
very important because you there's a
destination and there's a means to that
destination it turns out and this is
really most important is if you focus on
the destination and not on the means let
the system which is so powerful to it it
will get there without you telling it
how to get there but when you start to
interfere and say okay now I got to make
sure I swing it right my head's level my
grip is right and all of a sudden you're
putting all this details in it's like no
don't focus on the details you forgot
what the end was the end was the ball is
supposed to go over that there and so
that starts to come in because now
you're trying to control everything with
your you know with this manual control
and it's like no uh you don't have to
have the manual control matter of fact
that gets in the way the the body knows
what you want you don't have to tell it
how to get there that's a big issue in
our lives because uh I want to be
successful how oh I got to do this I got
to do this and I say oh you're you're
planning all these things uh and your
your conscious mind is not even any the
subconscious a million times more
powerful a computer than the conscious
mind so I say you're going to take this
little small conscious mind and try to
run the bigger computer it's like that
doesn't work let go of the control and
this is the whole thing I mean I mean
it's a i it just came to my mind a lot
of people say let go let God or
something like there some phrase that
people always say and I go well that's
actually the way to do it focus on what
you want but don't try and tell the
universe how it's going to happen don't
tell them that I'm going to do this and
this is going to happen I go no you just
focus on what you want the intelligence
of the super computer the subconscious
super
computer uh it will handle it unless you
put your hands into the machine I said
keep your hands out the machine focus on
where that Ball's going to go I mean he
already practiced remember I said we did
The Habit we did the practice whether
you're driving a car hitting the golf
ball practice practice you don't think
about the details of driving when you're
driving you know they just automatically
you could have conversation you could be
often thought and you're still driving
the car the movie The Matrix everyone
thinks science fiction I go no no no
that's a documentary everybody got
programmed that's a fact that's a
biological reality but what was
interesting they always say well there's
a red pill and if you take the red pill
you get out of the program and I go
guess what almost everybody in our
audience is taking that red pill at one
time change their life yes when was that
it turns out science has recognized that
when you fall in love you stop playing
the programs and you start creating from
your conscious mind wishes and desires
are conscious mind and so once you let
go with a program and you start creating
wishes and desires it's called the
honeymoon yes you created this Heaven on
Earth experience and I go and here's the
inside story that Michael's been telling
you for years but I can now tell you you
could have that every day for every day
of your whole life because we created
that and if you understand you created
then you can say well why don't I create
it tomorrow and I go you can create it
every day that's the beautiful part one
of the things that really upset me for a
long time was the fact that I had great
ideas and intentions and I wanted to
manifest him and I thought this is how
it's going to manifest and so I had all
these visions of how things were going
to unfold and then I'd start a process
and it wouldn't unfold and then it would
irritate me because it's like I got to
make it work I got to make it work uh
ultimately I started to recognize when
things didn't work it was possibly
because there were better ways to do it
and I wasn't conscious of it and so what
I started to learn over a period of time
was simply this there there's an old
saying there's a means to an end and the
idea well the end is your
destination and of course the means are
how you're going to get to that
destination well of course all of us sit
down and say yeah this is what I want
and then we start to figure out well
this is what I'll do to get to those
ends I'll get to this and I'll get to
this to get to the end what I started to
realize at some point was maybe my
awareness of how to get to the end
wasn't exactly accurate and it turns out
many of the times when things didn't
work and I was like so upset it didn't
work but it turned out oh there was a
better way to get there and I didn't
even know it so the universe was really
facilitating me uh and I wasn't paying
attention I was getting angry at the
universe because like it's not working
the way I want it to work and then I
started to realize at some point was my
God maybe the universe has a better
solution than the one I was even
thinking of myself so I really learned
over a period of time it's very critical
insight to help me get to where I am is
to focus on the on the end what is it I
really want put that Focus together and
it's very critical it's very interesting
because people have oh I would like this
and it's a broad General category and
then at some point it's look well it's
not specific enough you have to actually
say what it is you want uh I'll always
remember I was uh uh looking for a
special shirt to go to a Pink Floyd
concert and and I just all of a sudden
visualized oh it' be neat to have a
Russian shirt you know with a collar
that goes across here and a couple of
buttons down and I thought oh yeah that
would be really great that would be cool
shirt and then I stopped and I was
thinking where the heck do you get a
shirt like that I have no idea in the
world but I thought that would be pretty
good so I figur well I still got to get
something so I drive off to a mall up
near San Francisco and I walk into the
mall and there's a first men's store
over there and I go let's start look and
I have no idea and I walk in and of
course there's this big circular rack of
sail clothes I thought what the hell
it's only a Pink Floyd concert one night
let's see what's in there and I started
going through the rack and lo and behold
oh my God a Russian shirt right in the
middle of everything and it was like the
shock of oh my God there's a Russian
shirt right here the infor the
unfortunate part of
it was I had the picture of a Russian
shirt I said cool I never said what the
color was or anything else I just had
Russian shirt and there was a Russian
shirt color gray no color at all why I
didn't put in the concept of color
Universe said well just give it to them
in Gray and it was one of those things
like oh be conscious of what you're
asking for because the the more detail
you put in the more the universe can
manifest a resolution if you leave a lot
of blanks in what you want then all of a
sudden it's like well it's random
whatever fills in the blanks cuz you
never said what you wanted you can have
an idea what you want and that's
important but the most important part of
that just having an idea is not just
have a broad idea I want X and I go no
no what exactly do you want why
go back to the principles of Science and
the principles of science reveal
something very important that principle
of science is this Consciousness is
creating our life experiences I go well
that sounds new Agy I go no this is not
new Agy this is the primary principle of
quantum physics we are creators this is
a fact in fact quantum physics has that
but now let me add one other fact
epigenetics says the same thing because
epigenetics says your consciousness is
controlling your behavior and your genes
and so it's time to stop for a second
and recognize where is your
Consciousness what do you thinking about
and the idea is start thinking all those
very positive thoughts but don't try and
tell the universe how it's going to
manifest okay you think of the picture
let the universe get you there and
that's the most important lesson I've
learned I'm not telling the universe how
I'm going to get there I'm is saying
Universe this is where I want to go and
then the universe will take care of it
it's so powerful it is so wonderful and
I never believed in it for the first 40
50 years of my life but I can tell you
now the life that I'm manifesting today
is a consequence of just what I said
focus on the end don't tell the universe
the means to get there I was given an
opportunity to go to San
Francisco and have a big presentation at
a big conference on energy and crystals
and stuff like that and I thought well
there's going to be an audience their
energy and crystals like okay this
everything I'm talking about in biology
I was so excited and I thought this is
my great opportunity and it was like
like 3 months before and I thought okay
I'll I'm going to work on this and then
I just let it go I let it go and now
we're getting to a month before and I
said I got to work on my what's my
seminar going to be what's my seminar
and all I had in my head was okay this
was a new Agy kind of thing so I thought
well back then what the heck was new
aging I said oh that's where they wear
all white white shirts and white pants
and a white vest white clothes you know
and that they're so delicate and they
speak in a very quiet tone and they're
so new Agy and that really wasn't me I
was like the bull in the china shop you
know it's like hey and it goes no no
that's I got to calm down I got to be
cool I'm going to present this in a new
age fashion so I tried to formulate a
new age me to present present this well
now it's about a week before this
conference and it's like my new age me
has not come up with any idea of how to
present this and then it started to get
closer it was just a few days away I'm
going to go to San Francisco I like oh
my God I don't have a talk and I just
said forget it let me just be me I just
want to talk the way I want to talk I'm
not going to conform to be some new age
Guru that's not me I'm a science guy and
I'm going to say what I want to say and
finally that moment it was just a couple
of days before all of a sudden I said
that's it no more new age let's let's
write this and the moment I let go of
some Persona I was supposed to be and
just said n I'm just going to be me all
of a sudden the word started coming out
I can remember I grabbed a yellow pad
and I had a pen and the word started
coming so fast as soon as I said stop
being New Age Guy start being Bruce the
words start coming page after page I was
right I had like four or five pages of
notes notes notes notes like after all
those months it was sort of like okay it
was a little constipated in my
Consciousness you know but it all of a
sudden freed up and it's why I am not
them I'm
me and try to act like somebody else
took away everything I was and that was
at the point that said oh my God I'm
going to have I'm not going to alter who
I am I Love This research I'm not going
to tailor it for for that audience and
it was so wonderful because there were 3
months where it was just logging back in
my head back in my head yeah I got to do
this and do this like didn't want to do
it why cuz at some level the first thing
was I'm going to be somebody else I'm
going to be Mr New Age
guy the moment I let go of being
somebody else and became me then all the
words came down here's a simple truth
the first 40 years was struggle
life when I did this PSY and all that
stuff the last 30 years has been the
most enjoyment I could ever imagine in
life that I even wrote a book called the
honeymoon effect because the the the
harmony of what love brings into the
world you know when people on a
honeymoon it's like heaven on Earth and
I say for 30 years I've been living
heaven on Earth and and every aspect of
my life is so beautiful and why I
changed the limiting programs through
the process of Psych
and when I put in programs that gave me
uh the values I wanted the joy which is
so really important about it is I didn't
have to work on it once the program was
in there the subconscious running 95% of
the day automatically without my even
participating consciously I was Finding
heaven without even making an effort to
get there mhm and I am living in this
most wonderful life no doctors no
pharmac ceutical drugs uh no insurance
you either no me either why should I
spend the money for insurance I haven't
had Insurance since 1992 yeah I haven't
either uh and and the fact is what who
needs it I'm not I'm not planning to do
that right and the idea is what we
really ultimately come down to is life
isn't a bunch of accidents that we move
through life is a bunch of creations and
if your life is a struggle uh we always
have a tendency to say oh the universe
is against me or something like that
victim mentality I'm a victim I can't oh
it's out of my control it's that's the
problem not me and once you understand
the basis of the new biology and the
psyche process you start to recognize
why I am a co-creator of my life and if
my programs are not really good then my
life will not be really good changing
those programs and here I am today with
you and look how beautiful this woman is
she Sparkles and shines
why when we clean up the the problems
that we acquired in our development M
then life comes to us you don't even
have to go out and Chase it anymore and
that is the 100% difference first 40
years I'm going to go get that success
last 30 years open the door oh here you
are thank you very much yeah yeah so uh
all I can say is the most exciting
experience in my life was to Take Back
Control we become less
intelligent when we're
afraid and then I say well look at the
world day it's chaos it's fear I mean
the co thing scared everybody so much
they said don't even talk to anybody put
your mask on keep away from everybody
the business is shut down but I said oh
my God this is
fear and I go that is a result and that
happens inside the body everything shuts
down that would keep you going when
you're in a state of fear and this is
why over 90% of illness is directly
related to the stress that we're living
in in this world and you might say well
what about cancer I'm going to tell you
a most important fact this listen to
this there is not one gene that causes
cancer ah what about all the cancer
genes I say no those are genes that will
support the cancer but there are not
genes that cause the cancer I go wait
there's no genes that cause cancer I say
no I said ' then what's the cause you
ready disharmony in the biology remember
your cells are a community think about
it this way if you have a a a bad leader
of the community bad president or prime
minister I go then what happens I say
there's not happiness in the
community
disharmony and I said what if you have a
good leader and I said then the
community is right behind them
supporting them so I said but your mind
is the leader I say is your mind sending
good information I'm healthy I'm happy
I'm strong I'm in love I'm enjoying my
life or is your mind sending be careful
be afraid watch out somebody's going to
get you you're not going to have this I
go what's the difference and I go the
difference is that stress
hormone it uh shuts down your
maintenance of your body it shuts down
your immune system and it shuts down
your intelligence and when you stop
using your intelligence that's what's
controlling the community of 50 trillion
cells so all of a sudden it becomes
important to
recognize your Consciousness your
thoughts are the government
Consciousness is controlling your
genetic
activity when when people follow the
fate of a child adopted into a family
where there's cancer they find that the
adopted child child will get the same
family cancer at the same probability as
any of the natural siblings so an
adopted child picks up that gets that
cancer but here's the point the adopted
child came from totally different
genetics so it was not the genetics that
pushed that cancer it was being adopted
into a family where the programming was
not giving them uh wholeness health
happiness uh it's just U stressful very
stressful programming and as you said
stress American Psych olcal Association
recognizes 90% of doctor visits are
stress related
visits and the we don't focus on the
stress that's like oh a side thing I say
no it's not a side thing it's the number
one thing that is coming from the top
down uh and the genes genes are
blueprints to make the proteins of the
body 100,000 different proteins like
building blocks okay proteins are
complex molecules and they wear out prot
prots wear out all the time so you have
to replace them I said well how do you
replace this complex molecule and the
answer is DNA is a
blueprint to make a protein I go so what
I go well you go into an architect's
office and she's working on a blueprint
and I said well ask her is your
blueprint on or off and she would look
at go what are you talking about it's a
blueprint so on and off I go precisely
genes cannot turn themselves on and off
they don't
self-actualize they're controlled by
environmental signals and all of a
sudden oh my god well if the environment
is controlling this then you're
programming the environment your
lifestyle in the environment and all
these other things now become the
primary controlling factor of your genes
not the genes and we have to let go
because when I was programming the
doctors that oh jeans turn on and off
and all that stuff I was programming
that people are victims because as I
said as far as you know you didn't pick
the jeans you can't change them they
operate by themselves and so we were
programming victim and then it turns out
the new science of epigenetics is not
victim you're the one that's actually
controlling it with your behavior if my
thoughts are distorted because of animal
Soul when I broadcast these thoughts I'm
not activating what I want I'm
activating what the program wants and I
started to realize that because the
magnetic field as you said is shaping
our experiences in this world at this
point and that's what you can read with
Magneto andil graph you're reading these
fields which are your thoughts and then
I started to realize when the field is
being mainly run by the animal
Soul I'm not controlling that that was
the automatic program that's a program
that's not me that's program and I
realized I could observe me
doing the program but there's a point
like you recognize there's a point you
say wait a minute I'm the controller I
don't want that program I want to use my
human soul to run the
show and as you said same thing once you
start coming from the human soul you
override the animal soul and that's when
you become the Creator and because of
our creation not only is information
coming in but as the Magneto and seh
shows the information going out and I
say it affects the world we're living in
okay that's the experience you have now
but it also goes back to the original
spirit and this is the karma part where
my life experience has
distorted my spiritual
broadcast and I say well how how do I
get back and I
say it's very simple you just have to
know who you are and this is what you
said and it's true most people have no
idea who they are they think they're
this physical body and I said that's
what I used to think when I was
conventional science but once I
understood the physics and the role of
energy and Consciousness and spirit the
game changed for me I said wait a minute
I don't want to be animal soul I want to
be Bruce's soul I want brues to create
this not the not the program from mother
and father and culture I don't want that
one I want one and like you I started to
recognize well wait I can change I can
now I want to take the control now I
want put my hands back on the steering
wheel I want to drive this I don't want
the program to drive this you know the
cell phone that you have in your hand
yeah you can drive it by talking into it
but it also can work by itself because
it's got program and I think that you
and I have this information that we've
been trying to present to the world to
say take back the
control because you're more than this
body what I really would like to let
people know is while the world looks
totally crazy at this moment this is a
very important part of our Evolution and
the reason is uh human civilization has
been destroying the planet that we are
now facing what is called the six mass
extinction of Life on this planet and
and and since we are the ones that are
causing it it is based on our culture
and the way we've been living and not
treating nature with love and respect
that we are losing contact and so what
we see is breaking down is an old way of
life that is actually caus the problems
and that we're facing a new Evolution
and to do that you you can't build it on
the foundation where the problem is so
when you see the foundation breaking I'm
Not Afraid matter of fact I'm so like
yeah it's breaking because that's the
only way we can build a new one so I
just want people to realize when you see
the world falling apart it's not the bad
news it's actually the good news because
if we kept it the same
way Extinction is looming right in front
of us and I'm not talking a thousand
years I'm talking of decades and so um
welcome to the evolution start taking
care of ourselves and all of a sudden
it's like instead of being out on the
road okay uh you know I I I look at what
I eat quite differently uh I'm feeding
50 trillion cells in my community and uh
I like to you know I know for the
biological reason of giving in the
healthiest finest uh nourishment
possible because as a person who used to
grow cell tissue culture uh culture
medium is the equivalent of blood and we
grow cells in it and if you compromise
the composition of that culture medium
in any way the cells will get sick and
die and so we have to learn how to take
care of that so people are learning a
little bit about that we also have to uh
uh understand vitamins and supplements
are really good for us especially
vitamin C it's great for immune system a
lot of it it's really good uh and then
start to uh also look at maybe uh which
I'm going to go do right after this is
go climb a mountain right here in the
out across the road because I need to
get some exercise every now and then one
of the most important principles of
science is that our Consciousness is
creating our life experiences and yet
when you talk to people and you say
how's your life going it's like well
it's not really going the way I would
like it to go and then comes the most
important question I say well what is it
you really want you know what's
interesting you can ask people that
question most people respond saying well
I don't want this and I don't want that
and I go no what is it you want and I go
they never really focus on what they
want they just see what's not working
and say they don't want that and I go
but what does this lead to I say well if
you're focusing on what you don't want
you know I don't want this I say you
know there's a picture in your mind that
corresponds to what what you just said
your mind sees an image I don't want X I
don't want Y and I go well that image
you just said you don't want is an image
in the brain whose function it is is to
translate that image into reality
because Consciousness is creating
reality which means hey the placebo
effect is a reality based on positive
Consciousness and everybody goes yeah
positive thinking can heal me of any
disease I go yeah that's Conscious
Creation what we don't talk about is
that negative Consciousness manifests
equally powerfully as positive
Consciousness but it works in the
opposite direction and it's called no
seow effect it's just an expression that
negative thought manifest negative
reality it is simply impossible to
achieve long-term health and happiness
if you hate yourself 100% this is so
important because this is that was I
have a memory of a point in my life
where that changed just like boom just
like Tom already turned a switch because
I was on the edge of I could have been
diagnosed as manic depressive why it
happy most of the time but once it
started going wrong then it was like
this is wrong and then I give myself the
abuse verbally oh not you're stupid
you're not good enough what what's wrong
with you lipon and I'd be doing that and
I I was in my lab and I I just spent a
procedure that took about an hour to
prepare for the experiment and and if
you mess it up just a little bit you
have to start all over again the third
time that day I messed it all up and now
I'm really upset I spent the whole damn
day doing this it didn't work and then
I'm getting oh you idiot you can't do
anything right now was giving myself
like a parent on my shoulder telling me
where you're that's not good enough and
I'll never forget there I was alone in
the lab and I hear this
voice and there's sobody there I hear
this voice like you know and and the
voice says don't you have anything
better to do than to listen to this crap
and I looked around I started to laugh
because I said sure I'd rather go to a
movie so there was a newspaper I picked
up the paper I found a movie went off to
the theater guess what that whole
dialogue ended instantly I had a choice
I had that's what it was saying I have a
choice do you want to continue this
conversation or you want to do something
else that was the moment of empowerment
that was so great because it said
stop stop do something else get out of
here and and next time I started to get
a little depressed first thing that came
back was the humor of that and I'd laugh
and I go okay I'll do something else and
after three or four times guess what
I've never been depressed since that
time never why it it just doesn't hold
in my mind if a if a depression you know
like a negative thing starts happening I
don't sit there and play it over and
over and over again which makes you go
downhill downhill I just oh I don't I
have a choice it's a choice do I want to
listen to this stuff or do I want to do
something else everyone thinks disease
is related to genes and I'll tell you
what less than
1% of disease is connected to genes that
up to 90% of illness is stress related
and I go well what's the consequence
I'll tie it into the corporate thing in
a second because the first two uh
consequences of putting stress hormones
in your body are let's go back a few
hundred thousand years when the only
stress was the saber-tooth tiger chasing
you so stress is based on your ability
to escape uh and your ability to escape
is to use your arms and legs and I said
well yeah well you want all the energy
in your arms and legs because you know
uh you don't have to worry about the
gallbladder right now that's not
relevant to saber-tooth tigers coming so
there are three things that I want to
bring up so very number one the first
the first two are physical okay number
one is stress hormones cause the blood
vessels in the gut this area to shut
down in fact when you first feel fear
there's like a butterflies in the
stomach queasy feeling that's actually
the blood vessel squeezing shut and I
say why should the blood vessel squeeze
shut it's like you don't need to
maintain the body if you're trying to
escape the tiger so by squeezing the
blood vessels shut you send the blood to
the arms and legs more more energy uh
and most important part especially in
today's world is that stress hormones
shut down the immune system that's a
function it's so effective that when a
doctor wants to transplant an organ into
a foreign person and they don't want the
recipient's immune system to reject it
they give the patient stress hormones
before the transplant because stress
hormones shut down the immune system
reason is simple if you ever been sick
sometimes you don't even have the energy
to get out of bed and I go well you know
if you have a bacterial infection and a
saber-tooth tiger chasing you you know
it's like well who cares about the damn
bacteria because if the tiger catches
you the bacteria is not really a problem
anymore uh and so the uh immune system
is shut down which opens us up to a
problem and in today's stressed out
world the uh the amount of illness on
this planet with all the money we put
into Healthcare is rising all of the
time and I go it's because of the
stresses that we're we're dealing with
that's causing this Bruce do you have uh
in your work a general perspective on or
a definition or a way that you look at
addiction well basically what I have to
understand about biology is that
throughout Evolution um biological
systems are given information response
to how they how they deal with the world
around them we call them emotions
Sensations feelings symptoms Etc like
that one of the major aspects is this is
that nature has designed uh two senses
of pain and pleasure uh as a way of
teaching an organism to go in the right
direction in other words we're smart we
go to school we learn you know cross the
street look both ways and all that kind
of stuff like that but uh you got
smaller lower forms of life animals that
are moving through the world how do they
know where to go and where not to go how
to to do the right thing to stay alive
well nature uh has endowed them with a
sense of feeling and the significance
about that is we are given two
completely opposite senses one is pain
and one is pleasure when pleasure is uh
received by an organism or perceived by
an organism it really represents that
you're doing the right thing and that's
why nature encourages you says look this
is really good go this way but when you
start to do something that threatens
your survival or it's really not
supportive uh we receive a sensation of
pain and that's Nature's way of saying
look this is threatening to you this is
you know inappropriate behavior whatever
it is do something different uh and it's
kind of interesting because uh in our
civilization and throughout history that
was manipulated a bit by by the original
Church uh which looked at uh pleasure as
negative and pain is positive which is
like complete turnaround of the table of
biology some confusing messages there
absolutely but it it it really causes a
a profound um conflict in our biology
when our biology is telling us we're
doing something right gives us pleasure
and then our psychology is saying no no
that's wrong don't do that uh then we
have a conflict between programming and
biology and so basically what I see is
this is that when we find ourselves in
trauma and problems uh a we try to seek
a way to get out if you can't seek a way
to get out then you actually do some
kind of other Behavior or something else
to uh to lessen the pain because uh if
you can't move and you're stuck in pain
then what are you supposed to do just
living that well at our level of
cognition and awareness we can put in
some other behavior and and and and then
actually uh override the the current
experience
so what we have to recognize is when
people really are generally dealing with
an addiction problem they're really
first trying to overcome some kind of
pain in their life or threat to their
survival or their existence and then
choose another alternative Behavior
unfortunately the alternative behaviors
don't necessarily take you out of the
problem so you stay in the problem uh
but even though you're trying to get
mentally out of the problem knowledge is
power and lack of knowledge is a lack of
power when people don't know that
they're involved with their own life and
their own genetics and their own
behavior because they're programmed to
be the victim then they become a victim
because they have no knowledge of this
and and what you're doing what I'm doing
is let let's wake up you are powerful if
you understand how this works and if you
don't understand how it works you just
say no it's not me I'm not in control
and and people walk away feeling like
there's nothing I can do the genes are
controlling this and I don't control the
genes I go well that's the story that's
wrong and when people are allowed to
walk away from a medical practitioner
with that belief then that practitioner
in no way has helped that patient
because the idea is this as you said
I've got to help them get a better
attitude when they walk out of this
building I have to give them more power
so that they have more power because if
they walk out saying there's nothing I
can do then the game is over at that
point what is happening right now in the
world in society that you see where
things are are ramping up or are
they and why is it more more important
now than ever go ahead okay uh we're in
the process of an evolutionary upheaval
at this very this very time moment and
the upheaval is due to crisis and we see
the crisis around the world whether it's
economic religious racial whatever you
want I say those are trees in a forest
and I said if you get back a little
further away you can see the bigger
crisis is uh we are facing an imminent
Extinction of human
civilization uh and and it's this is
real and the public has been made aware
of it a long time ago and then sort of
disappeared that we are facing what is
called the six mass extinction of Life
on this planet which means five times uh
there were previous mass extinctions and
and the point about we always think
evolution is one continuous you know
from beginning to end it's like no it
start stops breaks starts again stops
breaks and it's done five times the last
uh mass extinction 66 million years ago
when the dinosaurs were here and a comet
hit near Mexico up ended the web of life
and then all of a sudden 75% of uh all
species
disappeared uh when that after that
Comet uh but today we're in What's
called the six mass extinction and why
we're bringing in here Abraham and Tara
is basically because science has
recognized for the last oh my God 15
years or more that human civilization
human
behavior is undermining the Web of Life
leading to our own
Extinction uh and just is there a number
I'll give you an interesting number the
uh World Wildlife Foundation in 1970
took a survey how many animals on planet
Earth uh they recently readed the survey
2third of the entire animal population
of the planet has appeared since the
first time they did it uh we're losing
species of organism faster than in some
previous as I said five mass extinctions
significance is this human behavior is
now has been recognized as the cause of
this we are undermining our
environment thinking that we are you
know a dominant in control of the
environment no we are the environment
you you you know uh the you know the
Grandeur of human thinking is a weak can
control and dominate danger is like well
how's that working the answer is facing
mass extinction in the next few decades
period so we have to change Behavior if
we understand what's going on we can
flow with nature instead of resisting it
yes and flow out of the chaos which is
not random but taking us to the new
world right and therefore uh if we can
learn how to change our behavior and
become more in harmony with the world
which is what nature is calling on us to
do MH then we can create a sustainable
thrivable situation right now uh it's
not sustainable uh the system is
crashing because we cannot maintain the
way we have lived so that means we have
to change the way we live and I go yeah
but that's culture and that's behavior
and so it says you have to change
Behavior then we have to let go of a
behavior to create a better behavior and
well most people have to hit their heads
against the wall and go through all this
process again what we've been talking
about is well can I make it easier and
the answer is of course you can make
make it easier uh we can do Psy balance
and change behaviors in minutes and so
we don't have to be part of the struggle
in the chaos we could already be at the
new end wait for the other people to
come out of the chaos and join us a lack
of knowledge is a lack of power and I
said you're suffering out here because
you feel you have no power and if you
really understand the biology that we're
talking about and the spirituality that
you're talking about and you start to
recognize it you recognize oh my God you
so powerful and yet you have a belief of
victim and since belief controls it no
matter how powerful you are if your
belief is your victim then you are
victim and we have been victimized by
beliefs that are incorrect and uh uh and
if we adjust the science it
automatically then comes right together
with the whole spiritual message that
agape and my brother Reverend here uh
have been providing for years uh but
there's a scientific context to it
because a lot of people go well is it
scientific I go yes it
is I mean I mean what what are those
flawed beliefs that that we've been
living under all these years well there
are four of them and two of them are
actually part of darwinian theory which
I'll mention but the first one that's
really important is people have been
programming the belief that the genes
they inherited at conception are
programming the rest of their life the
the genes we didn't select them as far
as we know if you don't like the Char
eristics you can't change these genes
and then we add on top of that we say
and the genes turn on and off by
themselves and all of a sudden you start
to realize then I'm not running my life
the genes are running my life oh my God
there's cancer in the family and their
genes are going I'm gonna get a cancer
Gene I'm and I say what's the belief you
already got the belief I'm GNA get
cancer I go this is trouble right there
right right right this little sidebar
because I love this sidebar there's not
one gene that causes cancer cancer is
not caused by a gene cancer is caused by
disharmony in your life uh unresolved
anger is the biggest one uh feeling lost
left out you know not part of something
is another one that separates you and I
want people to understand that because
so many people say oh I've got this
cancer and the gene does it and I'm just
a victim back here and the genes took
this and genes made this and I go stop
you are co-creating with those genes the
gene does not turn on and off and the
gene does not control things the gene
responds to the environment and if your
perception of the environment is not in
Harmony and support of your life that
disharmony is what can activate a gene a
gene is a blueprint just like in an
architect's office and I mentioned I say
you go into an architect office and
she's working on a blueprint you ask her
you say hey is your blueprint on or off
and she'd look at you like what are you
crazy it's a blueprint there there's on
and off I go yes DNA is a blueprint to
make the proteins of the body it cannot
turn itself on on and off you need an
architect Consciousness mind is
architect right that turns the genes on
and can modify the read out of the genes
well I could live in a perfectly healthy
happy environment that will support me
but if I perceive it's a negative
environment then my cells inside my body
do not know that it is a healthy
environment they only see the perception
that I send to them and this is why
perception becomes so important is
because the cells are not directly
touching the environment and depend on
the nervous system's
interpretation to adjust their biology
so if I change my perception my mind
change my belief about life I change the
signals that are going in and adjusting
the function of the cell the point is
very very significant and that is this
I'm not a victim of my genes because I
uh by my ability to change my
environment and by my ability to change
my perception of the environment have
the ability to control my genetic
activity I'm not a victim of my heredity
I'm a master of my genetic activity well
how do you change a program that was the
issue not how you change the conscious
mind how do you change the subconscious
mind because it doesn't learn conscious
mind learns by just whatever you read
the book I learned it okay uh
subconscious mind doesn't learn that way
I say how does it learn I say well in
the first seven years that's when I said
the programming went in the brain wasn't
functioning at the higher level of
Consciousness it was actually a little
lower that was called Theta the
vibration the imagination and all that
that's hypnosis okay so the first way we
learned programs was hypnosis because
the the the function of the brain wasn't
it was at a high at a low you know lower
vibration uh some people might remember
the old days when hypnotherapy they
they'd have a watch and the
hypnotherapist said you know swing the
watch back and forth and they would say
you're de getting tired you're getting
tired uh and what was the point when you
get tired you lower the vibration of the
brain and the moment you fall asleep
actually consciously the next level of
activity of the brain is Theta before it
goes down to the lowest vibration Delta
sleep so every night when you go to bed
there's a period just after you close
your eyes and you're essentially
disconnected for a moment your brain is
operating in Theta well Theta is
hypnosis okay so I said well that's how
you you your brain was in Theta during
that childhood period as predominantly
now you're an adult I said yeah but you
have Theta every night when you go to
bed so I said what can you do and this
is the old story you've heard people do
it you put a pair of earphones on at
night you play a program that you want
to be true in your life you and while
you're awake you might hear the program
but it's the moment you fall asleep the
conscious mind shut off but the
subconscious mind is now in record Theta
so whatever is coming through the
earphones at that moment after you fall
asleep you don't hear it but the
subconscious mind is hearing it and
downloading it in a state of theta so
the first way of changing a belief
system is to get into Theta uh and this
is called self- hypnosis put the
earphones on play the program programs
for health happiness love joy whatever
and just go to sleep which is really
cool because you don't have any there's
no studying here you just play the
program well the other day I was going
through my toy box and guess what I
found something I seen for a long long
time my wonderful wonderful ET a sketch
now many of you may have had this when
you were young as well but I really
loved it you know why it gave you an
opportunity to make a drawing on this
screen by turning these dials down here
and then after you complete the drawing
you can then Shake It Up and the drawing
will disappear and you can make another
drawing so it was like a reusable pen
and paper just shake it and make a new
one so here let let's take a look at how
you do it and I'll try it it's been a
long time since I've done it but uh let
me work at it here's how it
works so well you can see I'm a little
out of practice on it but here's the
beautiful part here's a drawing that I
just made and I created this image and
then manifested it on the screen of the
etra sketch so what's really interesting
is what I can do is now shake up this
screen and erase the image and then I
can create another one perhaps this one
is going to be a little better than the
last one let's see what I can do this
time well what a great picture but what
we can do is just shake it
up what the hell is going on behind me
oh my God the world is
collapsing so why is this relevant
because there's a lot we can learn about
Evolution through an etos sketch wow
what we're experiencing right now is a
process called Evolution well it's not
the evolution we learned in school the
Darwin version that's the kind of
evolution that says Evolution has
gradual changes over billions of years
imperceptible but over a long time you
see an outcome that's different in
contrast to the old version of evolution
the gradualism version there's a new
understanding Evolution called
punctuated equilibrium uh this is a
theory that was devised by Stephen J
ghoul and Niles Eldridge and what did
they recognize is that when looking for
fossils there were different layers
where fossils of animals that no longer
exist and then there's like a space and
then there's another layer with fossils
of animals that no longer exist and then
another space and they said well there's
something going on there's a development
a punctuation another development and a
punctuation the punctuations are natural
events that destroyed the nature and the
Web of Life at that time and in fact the
last one of these mass extinctions is
attributed to a giant Comet that hit
near the Yucatan Peninsula and upended
the web of life and at that last
Extinction 66 million years ago remember
before the comet hit the planet was
filled with lush tropical forest and
dinosaurs after the comet hit they don't
exist anymore the strata that we see in
the fossils is really the same story as
we see in the edes sketch the strata
means that something happened there was
a picture then the picture changed and a
new picture formed on the next strata
and then that picture changed the
understanding about the nature of the
etes sketch and what's actually going on
in our world right now are really the
same story we've created an image it's
not sustainable and and the edes sketch
is shaking but the planet is shaking the
planet is telling us that Civilization
you have created is no longer
sustainable and it's time for us to
create a more thrivable situation for us
to move into the future there's an old
saying there's no such thing as a new
story well if fact interesting point we
can go back thousand years and start to
recognize that the Buddhists were
telling us the same story in a different
fashion they were making what are called
sand mandalas and these are very ornate
Creations from different Sands instead
of paint different sand creating a
structure and then making this most
beautiful structure and they also
recognize just like the universe is
things don't always stay the same so
after they create this most beautiful
expression then they take all the sand
and scoop it all together and make a big
pile and start all over again for
another image just as in the story with
a mandala and the same story in the etes
sketch and the same story that we're
experiencing on this planet right now
there's a very important point that says
that we can move into the future but
take with us what we learned from the
past to build a better future to thrive
into that future and this is where we
are right now shaking it up so that
Civilization come together in a new
version with love Harmony and peace
while we're in this state of Chaos it's
a very important point about you the
Observer of what I've just been talking
about I go why is this important because
you represent cultural creatives you are
the people that are looking for answers
to how to get into the future from the
destruction we're facing right now and
the answers are not in the box so just
by even watching what we're talking
about right here is the idea to give you
the Insight of how powerful you are in
creating the new future your
participation is involved in this
Evolution this is not a passive event
you said at home and wait for evolution
this is where we go out and manifest
Evolution and just like in the story the
etes sketch you can put your hands on
the dial and start to create a new image
as well and so collectively when we all
work together the new image is a new
civilization one that can take us from
today into a future this is the moment
of manifesting a new civilization not
just for the people but for mother
nature herself and this is our
opportunity Unity to participate in
conscious evolution your life 95% is
coming from the program your life is a
print out of your programs you just look
at your life and recognize simple fact
the things that you like that come into
your life they come in because you have
a program to acknowledge those things
but the things you wish desire want in
your life and you work hard to make them
happen you struggled you sweat over it
I'm putting a lot of effort in I'm going
to make this happen why are you working
so hard and the answer is whatever that
destination is your program doesn't
support it and you're trying to use your
conscious creative mind to override the
program I said yeah but conscious mind
is 5% program is 95% I go it's not going
to work very well at all so that's why
poor people stay poor and rich people
stay Rich yep that's why the book Rich
Dad Poor Poor Dad that was exactly what
the whole point was if you grow up with
the programming of a rich family you
don't have to think programming is
subconscious your thinking might be
quite stupid I mean a former president
of ours was a relatively rich person but
not very smart in his conscious mind but
his program was how do I got how I got
rich by what he downloaded that from his
family okay uh and if you're in a poor
family what did you download oh Life's a
struggle it's not I can't get there as
you know you can change it I say yeah
how can you change remember I said well
there are two minds conscious is
creative wishes and desires subconscious
hard drive with a program I say the
conscious mind being creative can learn
from anything read a self-help book oh
yeah I know how to do that I said you
read the book I give you a quiz you get
a hundred and it says yeah you know this
stuff and then I say well now that you
know this stuff did your life change and
the answer is no I go why the conscious
mind learns from reading the book that's
not how the subconscious mind learns so
our smarts stay up here I read the book
I knew the information I understood how
it worked blah blah blah blah blah I go
yeah that's the thinking mind that knows
but I go does that translate into
subconscious I go no it doesn't because
that's not how the subconscious mind
learns you want to change the
subconscious then you have to put in the
data the way the subconscious mind
learns conscious mind creative can learn
from anything you could just go aha I
just changed my mind I can do that okay
subconscious mind habit point of habit
it resists change if a habit changes
then by definition it's not a habit
anymore so habits resist change and yet
we have these habits and we want to
change them I say how can you do it and
I say the only way you can change the
habits is the way that the habits were
learned in the first place I go what was
that I said first seven years your brain
was at a lower vibration than
Consciousness it was called Theta Theta
is hypnosis and I go oh so what do I do
I say well you you can't just say Okay I
want to go into hypnosis
hypnosis is part of a scale of low
vibration going to high during the day
and then when you come home from work
the high vibration slows down and goes
to sleep at the lowest vibration so you
go through a range of different
vibrations as you're sleeping Awakening
calm conscious Focus conscious you're at
work Focus conscious and I go then what
you come home you calm down now it's
calm conscious and then I say what then
you fall asleep I say the instant you
fall asleep the next vibration down is
Theta I go that's hypnosis I go yeah so
I say then every night the moment you
fall asleep the brain for a short period
of time is in hypnosis Theta so I say so
what well you put on earphones or
earplugs and you go to bed playing a
program that you want to be true in your
life I say so what I say you put it on
just before you fall asleep and while
you're still awake you probably hear
some of the program okay but the moment
you fall asleep conscious mind's
disconnected doesn't hear anything
coming off of the program anymore I say
but what does I say ah the subconscious
mind is in Theta record so whatever is
coming through the earphones is not
going into conscious mind but it's now
being directly downloaded into the
subconscious so this is called self
hypnosis you have to repeat this process
because the amount of time in Theta is
relatively short be before you hit the
lowest vibration Delta which is sleep
out right okay so every night when you
go to bed just after your Consciousness
falls asleep there's a period of record
opportunity and then you put the
earphones on play the program it's
called self hypnosis that's hypnosis
you're doing it yourself okay number two
you still learn programs after age seven
you learned how to drive a car you
learned how to play an instrument I go
well how'd you do it that way and I go
repetition habituation is practicing
something and repeating it and repeating
it so many many times that the
subconscious finally says okay I got a
pattern I got the pattern and that
pattern then becomes the Habit stress
hormones shut off the immune system okay
so that's two problems right away growth
maintenance shut off by blood vessel
squeezing shut immune system stress
hormones directly inhibit the immune
system so I'm not putting energy in to
internal problem when I'm being chased
and then I I always call the third one
the insult to the injury you just
injured your body now you would know
what the insult is I told you the stress
hormones in the in the gut squeeze shut
when you're in fear that's a butterflies
in the stomach you can feel it it say
queasy queasy and I go what else the
stress hormone shut the blood vessels
off in the thinking brain back right
here the the prefrontal cortex and when
the blood is squeezed the blood vessels
are squeezed shut here the blood is
pushed to the hind brain that's where
reflexes occur and reactions occur no
thinking so guess what under stress you
shut down thinking and now you're just
reacting and I go so you lost the power
of your Consciousness it's not working
negative thinking is equally powerful
but works in the opposite direction
meaning with positive thinking you could
heal yourself of any disease with
negative thinking you can die and create
any disease you can create your own
death just because you believe you're
going to die and all of a sudden I say
well then it's the power of belief
positive or negative that is shaping the
world and I go well this is why when we
look at people's beliefs and and they
they do you know an assessment of they
find out over 60% of the beliefs that
we're manifesting every day are negative
and disempowering self-sabotaging
thoughts that we've acquired such as I'm
a victim of my genes that's a belief and
somebody says yeah well I'm going to die
of canc because it's running in my in my
family and they get cancer and then they
find out there's no Gene that causes
cancer oh I'm I'm saying this on uh on
LY show I will have to emphasize that
there is not one gene that if you have
this Gene you have cancer genes are
correlated with cancer genes are not
causing cancer this is why half the
women that have the breast cancer Gene
brca2 half the women never get the
cancer they all possess a gene so
where's the point they said the gene
didn't cause it it was a lifestyle that
was not in harmony that ultimately
activated what is called a cancer Gene I
said so what do you mean so if you
change your thoughts you can get rid of
cancer I go yeah well that's what
spontaneous remission is all
about and so um I'm stepping on
Lindfield here because this is where
this emanation of thought and we don't
see it and we don't in our history oh
that's just thoughts and feelings I go
those are the controls that are
manifesting your life your thoughts and
your feelings your feelings are the
translation of the energy into sensation
so your feelings are like a compass
they're telling you whether you're going
toward more life or to less Life Energy
psychology is a new version of
psychology that engages something called
super learning super learning what's
that I go maybe you seen somebody read a
book by moving their finger down the
page just as fast as they move that
finger down the page they read
everything on both you know on the page
on both Pages boom they could just read
it so the idea is this well what if you
can engage super learning and uh use
that in downloading a new Behavior you
ready you can change a belief you had
your whole life 50 60 years you can
change that in minutes because super
learning is the equivalent of pushing
the record button on on the subconscious
super learning allows you to download a
new program in minutes and we need that
why because the behavior that the
culture and civilization using today is
so out of harmony with nature that
humans are causing their own Extinction
at this moment it's called a mass
extinction NASA scientists have have
already told us that industrial
civilization the one we're in uh is
facing and I I want to emphasize this
because it was in the title of the
report and I just I said we are facing
an
irreversible collapse of civilization in
the next couple of decades well we're
seeing it right now civilization is not
working the chaos that's all over the
planet is a sign that it does not work
this way and if we don't change then
we're facing our own Extinction what do
you mean by being able to change inner
Evolution because we all really really
do believe that genes are
Destiny well the biggest story comes
down to knowledge is power and everyone
goes yeah we all know knowledge is power
but let me put it in a better way for us
now a lack of knowledge is a lack of
power and a misperception by definition
is a lack of knowledge and now I have to
say we have been for the last 50 years
operating under two very uh important
misperceptions a the one you brought up
genes control our life this is totally
false uh and the second one is actually
uh the idea of a Newtonian universe
that's split into physical matter and
invisible energy and two different
Realms and they don't communicate and
whatever is physical should be you know
interfered with by something that's
physical so that's why we have
pharmaceutical drugs we have a physical
body you want to fix it you have to give
it something physical so those are the
drugs and that's an outdated and
disempowering illusion because it turns
out it's energy and Consciousness that
shape the world and and and let me just
emphasize it so it's not so it's so
weird sounding Consciousness our mind is
creating this well quantum physics is to
me the most valid science on the planet
uh even before it was fully understood
the theoretical ideas that were
presented have all been actually realize
that uh that this is such an amazing
science quantum physics and I say so
what's relevant about this valid science
I go the first principle in quantum
physics is consciousness is creating our
life
experiences and uh you know that's oh
that's so new age IO no that's about as
hardcore science as there is and uh this
Consciousness and and this is why I love
working with you Lynn because your job
has been raising consciousness around
the world and and that is how we're
going to evolve is uh not physically
evolve but we're going to evolve with
Consciousness and so uh the knowledge uh
that you're providing for people is
empowering and I like to do the same wow
looking at the world and seeing what's
going on right now all the chaos the
upheaval that's going on is so
distressing at one level and it's
interesting for me because as a
scientists I can stand up and talk about
the fact that today's chaos is a
necessary requirement for the evolution
that we would love to see and yet I like
you have to live in this crazy world
it's mindblowing it's crazy and it
becomes really important because all of
this stuff that we're hearing is
motivating fear and fear by its
definition is disempowering because when
you're in fear you're expressing I have
no power to take care of myself and we
give up power and we give it up to other
people to create the world for us and
obviously by look looking at this
computer and watching what's going on
around the world those so-called leaders
are not really helping us get to the
destination of a heaven on-ear reality
and it's time to recognize yes fear
takes away our power I've talked about
that in many many lectures talked about
the fact that stress hormones actually
shut down our Consciousness and puts us
into a reactive mode well this is not a
time for reaction this is a time for
creation and this this is what the
emphasis of quantum physics has been
telling us that it's our Consciousness
that is making creation and yet if we're
living in fear and Consciousness is
coming from Fear then what world are we
creating well that's the chaos we
observe every day on the news so in this
situation what we really have to do is
just listen to the words of Franklin D
Roosevelt when he said the only thing we
have to fear is fear
itself also relevant today are the
profound words by Frank Frank Herbert in
Dune where he says fear is the mind
killer and this is what we have to
recognize well I've been talking about
the fact that Consciousness is created
in our world and I say it's based on
science well let me give you a very
important fact it was in 1927 in the
founding of the science of quantum
physics that we get the most important
Insight from one of the founding fathers
of quantum physics Max Plank and what
does Max say all matter originates in
exists only by virtue of a force we must
assume behind that Force the existence
of a conscious and intelligent mind he
concludes this
mind is the Matrix of all matter well
that was what 70 more years ago 100
years ago I see has that changed I go no
look at this for example this is an
article out of the most prestigious
scientific journal on this planet nature
and I say what's this article I said
it's called the mental Universe it's by
a Quantum physicist at Johns Hopkins
University I'm not going to go and
describe everything he says in the
article because Richard con Henry the
author summed it up in the last sentence
let me emphasize for you that last
sentence in this article on quantum
physics the universe is
immaterial it's mental and
spiritual live and enjoy the most
important aspect about sleep is that it
gives a chance for the body to
re-calibrate its system so when
Consciousness is out then uh the body
starts to balance everything that's
going on you know with each system the
body's pH the temperature regulation
very interesting point that when people
are chomos uh they're in a hospital and
they got all the wires on them and
everything they run at a beautiful just
just beautiful like idling speed they're
com toes but their body is maintained a
balance and Harmony and everything is
great in the body level but as soon as
they become awake then the parameters in
the body all start to change because
it's our Consciousness that is is
creating the the functions of our body
uh and it's really important for people
to understand this is that quantum
physics is the most valid science on
this planet in regard to its theoretical
insights
um and the number one principle in
quantum physics is consciousness is
creating our life experience that's the
most important understanding because it
says we're not just a a machine but
we're like a remote control machine
there's a uh an energy field that is
being picked up by each of us that is
different uh the the field that's being
received is different for each person
the subconscious mind is 1 million times
more powerful and works 95% of the time
versus the small conscious mind working
5% I said that's the one that's stressed
that's the one that's struggling it says
I want something and I'm not getting it
and I'm going to make it and I go you're
trying to change the world when your own
behavior was the one that was sabotaging
it and that's because you didn't see
your programs and like Bill you engage
these programs and you don't even know
you have these programs but then as I
said well if you want to see your
programs your life 95% coming from the
program your life is a print out of your
programs the things you like as I said
they come in they came in because you
have a program to acknowledge them but
if you understand the things you
struggle over are not because the
outside is preventing you from getting
there it was your own invisible 95% of
the day playing programs you didn't even
know you had and that's where the
sabotage comes from and yet we want to
blame and fix everybody on the outside
and think that we're just the recipients
of all this without recognizing we're
the Creator of all this and that sounds
like oh so new Agy and I go listen
quantum physics is the most valid
science on this planet and principle
number one quantum physics Consciousness
is creating our life experiences you
want to change your life you don't
change the world you change your own
Consciousness the world changes after
that in the year 2018 astronaut Dr Bruce
Lipton set out on a voyage to save
Humanity upon the assumption that Earth
was dying and humankind needed a new
home
however just prior to launch new studies
emerged from Chernobyl the once
devastated landscape has regrown Nature
has returned unfortunately something
went terribly wrong and Dr Bruce Lipton
was sent into outer space many problems
occurred and Dr Bruce Lipton became lost
lost in the vastness of
space this is his journey after 20 long
years being Lost in Space Bruce Lipton
is is finally coming home oh wow what a
welcoming site look at that beautiful
blue green gem floating in the darkness
of space of going home it's going to be
great now if I could just get this ready
for re-entry Michigan troll Michigan
troll astronaut Bruce Lipton coming back
home from the outer limits with our
beautiful rocket ship please come
[Music]
in I guess well maybe they're they're
just busy right now but well I got such
a great story to tell them when I get
[Music]
back oh fresh air man being in that
little can for 20 years out there this
oh it's so wonderful oh it's beautiful
it is beautiful here God just think
about and how much time I spent out
there in open space looking for another
place for us to live another planet and
I come back here and look at this it is
so beautiful I didn't ever have to leave
gosh when I left here this whole place
seemed to be falling down man the
environment was collapsing all around us
the rainforest were being cut down
people were destroying the air the water
the land look at it now wow these people
have really created something new ah
created something new well that's not an
accident a creation is a participation
at that time when I left and the world
looked like it was on its last stages
something happened they people must have
learned how to change the world but in
order to do that they first really had
to learn how to change themselves you
really have to understand at some level
if we're going to create a garden like
this and somewhere along the line we had
to create the own garden in our own
Consciousness first and that's where we
start to come from reality humans have
imagination they can imagine a garden
but then humans have the ability to
manifest recognize this you have 50
trillion citizen cells living under your
skin a community that lives in harmony
if we really want to understand how to
live in harmony well look within that's
where the answers are how can 50
trillion cells provide for a happy
healthy human being because they
understood the nature of community it's
a fractal universe and fractal Universe
simply means this a structure geometry
of the universe represents As Above So
Below meaning if you understand the
structure at any level you can
understand it at any other level and so
if we really want to understand how to
create this beautiful planet then we
have to recognize this how did the cells
do it in our body because 50 trillion of
them came together in a community and
learned to live in harmony and provide
for their environment but then if we
understand how the cells did it then we
can understand how the people can do it
because we have to use the same
principles it's fractal to change that
planet and make it the garden that it
has become right now but then of course
you can't get there if you don't know
where you're going so before we even
embark on the trail we must first
visualize in our Consciousness what is
it we're seeking what are we trying to
manifest where are we going and once we
get that picture in our mind then we can
become the artist to manifest that
picture in the real world situation and
just by the looks of this Garden we
obviously must have learned our lesson
and of course where are these
people where are these
people hello hello
hello you Maniacs you finally did it you
blew it up damn you all die
H and in today's world we're told don't
go by the feelings if I did I would have
probably been better off at this moment
so when we recognize we have to make a
decision we can do it in two fundamental
ways first do an assessment an analysis
of step by step what does this decision
mean and why should I choose it but when
you get to the end before you absolutely
take that information and make a
decision based on that ask your heart
and the reason why is this the heart
doesn't care about the individual steps
in the decision the heart only looks at
the conclusion either you get more
energy from this decision a good vibe a
feeling that this is right or the heart
will give you a feeling of bad vibes
less energy a feeling that maybe this
isn't the right answer so the
significance is really profound because
the heart just reads energy and higher
energy is is more life less energy is
less life so in making a decision yes
it's acceptable to do the analysis but
before you come to that final decision
please check in with your heart feel the
feelings if the feelings are good that
means go toward that direction but if
you feel questioned about it you feel
weaker about it doesn't just feel right
the heart is telling you right off that
that energy is not good for you and you
should use some other decision oh wow
that's so wonderful what a wonderful way
to make a decision based on these
feelings and they can help us find the
direction that we need to go in and lead
us to a better
[Music]
life uh-oh I guess that's not really
working for me at this moment whoops oh
well computer and
simulation
[Music]
Scotty how many times have I told you
not to leave me off and se you know I
can't swim meet me at the bridge you
have some splaining to do what are some
daily affirmations you started to
implement when you saw this depressed
thoughts coming in or these
self-sabotage thoughts coming in what
did you shift it with affirmations with
different thoughts what did
it was just the awareness a that you
know as I said the very first stop light
where I started all of a sudden listen
while I'm waiting for the light it was
like the first time I tuned in and go
what the hell are you
thinking that was the most important
thing because then the habit of not
going there anymore starting to realize
uh oh this why am I thinking it's
negative thing turn around make a
positive statement right now because
that negative one is taking you on the
and just a repetition of this Behavior
become habitual so and habits are great
why no effort I love habits why you
don't even have to think about them they
do it automatically you know so if you
put in these really great habits you can
walk through the day and think anything
you want do anything you want and your
habits if they're good ones will just
guide you perfectly through here without
even being involved with
thinking that's the game the game is
what is heaven to you then program that
that's your life and then guess what the
95% of the day manifesting Heaven while
you're not even thinking about it once
you have identified your
programs how can you change what do you
do with them that always comes up
because that's the most important
question after you understand how it
works the most important question is
well how hell do I change the program
and I go this is the critical part the
conscious mind is creative which means
you can think of anything the
subconscious mind is prog programmed
it's got habits I go so what I say
habits when you have them it's a habit
you do not want to change a habit which
is important you learned how to walk
before you were two I'm glad you don't
change your habit because you'll forget
how to walk I said nope same program you
learned before too can carry you a
hundred years same program okay habits
do not want to change because if a habit
changes then by definition it's not a
habit so the subcon m is habit mine I
say yeah but how do I change I say
there's three ways only that you can
control this number one how' you get the
habits in the first place I say for
seven years my brain was at a low
vibration called Theta which is just
below
Consciousness and Theta is the direct
hypnosis line to the subconscious so
when you're in Theta whatever you're
experiencing at that point can be
downloaded straight into into the
subconscious I said well how do you get
the Theta I say interesting every day
when you're up at work you got a high
vibration in the in the brain that's
again with the wires on your head e EEG
the high vibration is called beta that's
like School room studying focused
Consciousness when you come home and
relax the vibration goes lower now it
goes into what is called alpha alpha is
calm relaxed
Consciousness but when you get really
calm and you're really relaxed guess
what Alpha shuts off you're sleeping
when you when Alpha is off you are
sleeping but for the next period of time
right after you fell asleep the brain is
operating in Theta and then it goes to
the lowest vibration deep sleep Delta so
Theta is a period when your mind goes to
sleep it's open for a little while and
Theta is hypnosis so if you put
earphones on
and you play a program at night when you
go to bed every night you go to bed just
before you fall asleep you put the
earphones on you play a program of a
program about health a program how to
make money a program how to be you know
uh relationships self-help program okay
at night you put the earphones on when
you go to
bed and as soon as you fall asleep
you're not awake anymore Alpha close
you're in Theta record whatever is
coming in through the earphones is not
going into the conscious mind it's going
deeper into the subconscious it's called
self
hypnosis you put the pro you put the
earphones on you repeat that because
Theta is not a long period after you
fall asleep but if you repeat it every
night you'll get information into the
subconscious so number one self hypnosis
earphones at at night play a program
that you want to be true okay and then
will automatically happen this is a
demonstration that and it's fun why you
were sleeping you didn't even have to do
any work you just had to go to sleep and
the work would be automatic so when you
wake up after playing this at night uh
the subconscious will have a new program
and one day you wake up and you're
living the new program without even
playing the tapes anymore it's once it's
in it's in okay so number one is
hypnosis self hypnosis
okay but after age seven the brain is
not in hypnosis
uh and now Consciousness is working I
said but you can still learn a program
you can learn a habit I say how practice
repetition you want to drive a car well
I'm not getting in the car until you
practice why because it's the practice
that makes the program strong I need to
empower the people because they have
been invisibly disempowered without the
knowledge that their life is coming from
programs that they didn't even put in
there right so true and these programs
rarely support what you want so you play
the programs and all you find is you're
not getting what you want those programs
never gave it to you you know a famous
book uh kosaki wrote a book called Rich
Dad Poor Dad this is truth here is
simple truth if you grew up in a rich
family you were programmed how to be
rich and how to have money if you grew
up in a poor family you were programmed
to recognize you don't have any money
you don't have any power and I say then
a rich person will stay Rich why because
95% of their life is coming from the
programs they downloaded from the rich
parents who made all the money the poor
person is going to stay poor because 95%
of their program comes from the poverty
mentality that their family experienced
when they were young and all of a sudden
it says well then you got programmed you
want to be a rich kid or a poor kid I
said well what the hell was your program
right and the big one that we're talking
about David is the program of fear
because we've all been programmed with
some Vision other people people have
told us about the afterlife the fear the
hell the damnation oh I don't want to
die I go hey from what are called
near-death experiences where people have
died for a period of time almost every
one of them said the exact same thing it
was better out there than it was back
here again and you know because a lot of
them when having this experience or
giving a choice do you want to stay here
in the afterlife or you want to go back
and most of them would prefer to have
stayed there but have obligations and
came back right but the point was yeah
you're not this physical body you're the
broadcast you're the energy but when
you're playing through this body then
you're the experiences of your life at
this point when you're out of body you
are the energy and the energy is forever
people don't realize the power
programming I'll give you one right now
cancer is one of the leading cause of
death in in in the world right now and I
go but what I go there's no Gene that
causes cancer what oh there are enco
jees we call these cancer genes like the
breast cancer Gene I go those are genes
associated with the cancer they don't
cause the cancer for you know example so
many women live in fear of the breast
cancer Gene cuz so many have it but they
live what's the fear I'm going to get
the cancer I have the Gene and I said
that fear is a vision which is
manifesting into their reality but then
I go you know 50% of the women that
carry the gene never get the cancer I
said what's the point the point is this
possession of the gene didn't cause
cancer it was a lifestyle that was
undermining your biology that activated
expression of these genes the gene
didn't activate itself so all of a
sudden it says oh my goodness then the
idea of cancer didn't come from the
genes I go no it came from the
programming programming of disharmony
dysfunction not living in life the fears
that are program because our
Consciousness is creating this world oh
that's quantum physics oh yeah that's up
in genetics oh yeah that's absolutely
right that's Placebo I go what do you
mean I'm sick and the doctor says this
the greatest newest research pill ever
it's going to cure you you take the pill
you get better and you go oh yeah that
was great and then you find out the pill
was a sugar pill there's a very
important point then what the hell heals
you right the conscious belief
that you would be healed manifested
healing and oh yeah Placebo my thoughts
manifested my reality that's exactly
what it's all about and yet while we are
a discussion of placebo what people
don't discuss which is much more
important to understand is well positive
thinking can heal us negative thinking
is equally powerful than controlling the
character of our lives so that negative
thinking can cause any disease even
death if you just believe you're going
to die you can die just from the belief
of it what is the immune system well
generally it's something that protects
me from what from things that get inside
your body and I said well why should
things want to get inside my body in the
first place let's set up a
scenario you're out there in the world
and I drop you off in the wilderness and
I say okay survive and one of the things
you have to do is start finding food and
you're going to spend all your time
maybe find nothing and you're going to
be looking for food and here's an
alternative Vision I drop you out and
eat all you can Buffet well you don't
have to worry about food it's being
served to you all the time what does
this have to do with the immune system I
go like this bacteria parasites that
live out in the environment have to
struggle for their survival to find food
but underneath your skin the tissues
inside your body are flush with fluid
from the blood and in that fluid are all
the nutrients and elements necessary for
growth so if a bacteria could find
itself inside to your body it would be
sitting pretty all it have to do is just
sit there and food would be constantly
delivered from an individual circulatory
system so the idea is well yeah then
obviously this is a nice environment
that uh invasive organisms would like to
find themselves in because it's like
free food what you know no problems so
okay so what does this mean it says well
then we have to have a defense system
because if invasive organisms get in
there not only will they utilize the
food we make but they could create a
toxic waste environment that could
actually undermine our health so we
can't afford to have invasive organisms
come into us and take over and the
immune system's job is an internal
protection system as opposed to for
example the adrenal system fight or
flight which protects you from threats
on the outside immune system protects
you from threats on on the inside so I
said well how does it work well the
immune system is an intelligent system
because what is the function of the
immune system to go out into the world
of their body and look for things that
are new that came in and then not only
recognize them but learn about them so
that they could create antibodies for
example to effectively knock them out so
the immune system's character is
learning and memory I go wow what a
coincidence this is the character of the
nervous system point the immune system
is an extension of the nervous system
learning in memory about the environment
in which you live so I said well how
does it work well I say that there are
organisms that prefer to find the
interior of our body as a place to live
because it's so much easier for them
just to sit there and uh live off of
your energy and your nourishment so the
old story is oh the immune system uh
protects self my body against invading
organisms as everything else is called
not sell well I go that's a crude
Insight but it's not anywhere near
accurate for a simple reason the immune
system identifies things that get into
the body that cause disruption of the
system and its job is to identify them
mark them and eliminate them I go but
there you know there are many organisms
that live with us that are part of us
it's called the microbiome thousands of
species of organ M bacteria and
parasites living with us I say the
immune system doesn't attack them the
reason is this they support our
viability they support who we are so
self versus not self that's not the
discriminating Factor the immune system
factor of the immune system is anything
that's disruptive to the system well
guess what that not only includes
organisms that came from the outside but
even our own cells if they go Rogue like
go into a cancer State the immune system
system's job is to eliminate them so
basically the function of immune system
is to keep Harmony in the system any
organism that comes in that disrupts
Harmony function immune system eliminate
what are the main limiting beliefs that
you just hear consistently that most
people tend to have if they're not in a
have a uh higher level program that
they've caught and switched with one of
the main beliefs that they're caught up
in is the uh lack of power they feel
over their own health and their own
reality that I'm a victim I'm a victim
of my genes I'm a victim of this world
out here I say if you if a the belief
system uh is translated into Behavior if
I believe I'm a victim then my behavior
will be as a victim no power you guys
tell me what to do and I'll try and do
what you just said and I say well that's
the biggest problem of all because
quantum physics I mentioned is a most
valid science and principle number one
is you're the creator of this it's like
well when are you going to own that and
the answer is I could say it but then
you walk away in a few minutes later
you're back into your world again
everything is gone you know listen took
me a while uh I learned and understood
that oh my God this is how it works and
I was so excited I wanted to get people
I wanted to tell anybody that listen to
sence this is how it works so I I
beginning got some people together and I
started to go off let me tell you how to
create the most beautiful life
experience and then they'd look at me
and they go you know lip in for a guy
who says you know this your life doesn't
look that good interesting it was my
wakeup call that said how the can I talk
about how wonderful this is and I'm not
practicing it and I immediately said to
myself no don't go out there and talk to
anybody about this why until you do
it so what were the what were the things
that were holding you back before you've
discovered this and then what was the
new program that you started to
implement for yourself on a consistent
basis to have 100% upgraded program yeah
well um one of the things professionally
okay I was doing a great job I I had a
great professorship in a medical school
all that kind of stuff you know
personally my life sucked really get a
relationship off the ground I go why not
I go well now that I know about it I was
programmed about relationships by
observing my father and my mother well
they had dysfunctional relationships so
what do you think I downloaded
dysfunction so my conscious mind goes
forward and says yeah I want to have a
great relationship I get into it my
subconscious mind steps up and says this
is how we do a relationship you oh uh oh
game over you know why because I didn't
see the negative behaviors that I was
putting out my partner potential partner
saw them and gave them cause for alarm I
don't think I want to be with this guy
you know that was me and then I realized
that and that's when I really had to go
in first thing and start to change who
am I and I'll tell you the biggest
problem now after years of working
people do not love
themselves and I said what does that
mean I said if you have a program where
you don't love yourself then rationally
logically can anybody else love you the
answer is no because you don't think
you're lovable that's right somebody
says you are that oh I love you and then
you go well you know you probably don't
have any quality control I know I'm not
lovable what's wrong with you you know
and then at some point you push them
away and then they're not there then you
go I'm not lovable nobody's here I I
pushed them away you know and I changed
that I was nearly what 45 years old 40
some years old and I had zero quality
relationships for all that life right
Chang a program and within a couple
years I I'm now with my partner
Margaret and and the fact is she was
involved with a um workshop training
program for people so she understood
processing and stuff and when I came and
we added the science and the processing
uh we've been living a honeymoon for 26
years really years waking up every day
going wow still here another day for fun
another day for being in love it was
great and it still is but if I didn't
change the program that would never have
been part of my life at all I would have
been my whole life struggling it's been
a very strange year on this planet chaos
is happening all over the place and
we're looking at this going on what's
going on with our world it seems like
it's turning upside down the answer is
it is turning upside down now that might
be the bad news for most people but it's
actually for my insight it represents
the good news you go how could it be the
good news news that the world is so
filled with chaos and the answer is
simply this is that human behavior has
precipitated the six mass extinction of
Life on this planet which includes us
five times in the history life was
thriving on this planet in some event
like a comet hitting the Earth upended
the entire ecosystem wiping out up to
90% of life this is the six mass
extinction and the source of this is
much closer to home than a comet because
the source of our Extinction is human
behavior we are undermining the web of
life and as a result there's a collapse
of nature going on all around us if we
don't change we're going to go extinct
I'm not talking A Thousand Years folks
I'm talking decades from now so what
you're seeing is a collapse of a
foundation civilization is changing so
rapidly Co has pushed it super fast all
of things are changing with the co the
way we work on the world and we commute
on the world things like that are
profoundly different now we're moving
into a different way of life we are not
going back to the old way of life we are
creating a new version so when you look
at the world falling apart Don't Be
Afraid actually be very joyous why if it
doesn't fall apart Extinction is right
here in a few decades if it falls apart
it gives us an opportunity to create
something better to move from here to
there frequently I'm asked every day how
come you look so happy and the answer is
I wake up happy and why do I get this
happiness where's it coming from and the
answer is this it's another day on
planet Earth and what's so exciting
about it is it's another day that I have
no idea what's going to happen but the
greatest wishes and desires for some fun
and excitement and a very joyous life so
I start off with today's going to be a
great day and almost every day it ends
up being a great day doesn't mean
everything works right but the beautiful
part about it is I've really learned not
to carry anything forward that is not
really happy and enjoyous in my life uh
it reminds me of a story two Buddhist
monks are walking along and Buddhist
monks are not allowed to touch women at
all and these two Buddhist mons are
walking along and they come to a river
and at that River there's a woman
dressed in her wedding Refinery and
she's crying and she's crying because
she can't get across the river wearing
these clothes so one of the monks just
picks her up carries her across drops
her off on the other side then the two
monks continue walking and about an hour
and a half down the road one monk says
to the other one how could you pick up a
woman and the one who picked up the
woman looked at him and said I I dropped
her off in an hour and a half ago why
are you still carrying her and the whole
idea about that is the meaning of it is
when events happen in our life it's not
necessary to keep carrying them
especially if they're negative ones you
can just stop right there and go on to
the next thing it's a choice do I want
to be in an environment where I'm not
happy or do I want to be in an
environment where I am happy oh Choice
well obviously but most of us have that
choice but are so caught up in
conventional rules and conventional way
of mannerisms and social structure that
oh we hold ourselves in places we don't
even want to be and then we sit there in
our mind getting aggravated by the whole
fact that I don't even want to be here
and I go well then guess what choice
pick a place you want to be go to the
movie go to something else break the
pattern and when you break the pattern
is your moment of power because when the
pattern is broken there's new choices at
that moment but if you don't break the
pattern you're going to follow a Litany
of up or down depending how you started
off the process the litany down not a
great trip I'll tell you that but hey I
think it's over 20 some years I haven't
been depressed I haven't even been angry
I get upset by some things of course but
it doesn't mean I hold them I drop that
person off on the other side of the
river and stop carrying it and this is
the choice it really is a choice you
have to think about it because it's it's
a conscious Awakening at a moment that
gives you a choice that wakes up and
goes do I want to do this and that's
that moment of choice you take that
moment of choice and then you say I'm
moving into where I want to go you make
a habit out of this because you repeat
this and then guess what you don't even
have to think about it anymore because
the subconscious program will always
redirect you to the place you want to be
and the whole other world that we used
to experience that used to irritate us
and aggravate us and all that anxiety
stuff it just doesn't exist and it
doesn't mean everything's going right
but the whole beautiful part about it is
well if it doesn't go right okay stop
now let's go do something else because
it's the idea it didn't go right and
then why didn't go right and who didn't
make it right and where is it going to
go now and BL blah blah blah and what
are you doing you're digging a hole and
it's not going up it's going down and
the whole idea is choice but the most
important part of choice is you have to
stop long enough not get caught up in in
the in the program and play out the
program there's a moment while you're
playing the program maybe you can
separate and look at yourself and say
why am I doing this because that is the
moment of power that is the moment where
you can say I have a choice I can do
something totally different than to Stew
in this stuff and then you are a
powerful person I think this is one of
the best things that we both can do
right now is to help people recognize
how truly powerful they are even though
they've been programmed saying I'm a
victim I said no you're not and there's
a science behind it and that's why I
love talking with you because there's
the spiritual part which I never was
spiritual for 40 years I was a Science
Guy genes chromosomes blah blah blah and
then in the study of the cells the cells
taught me that we're not even in here
we're broadcast playing through here and
and when you understand why which was
which blew my mind because hey I wasn't
spiritual and all of a sudden I said oh
my goodness the cells have little
antennas on them and each of us has a
different set of these antennas which
are receiving a broadcast yes in physics
you might say the word field which is uh
let me Define it and invisible moving
forces that influence the physical world
and I go same definition for Spirit
invisible moving forces influence the
physical world I said oh my God quantum
physics has revealed to us that we're
this energy spirit and we come in and
play through the body and our each of
our bodies have a different sets of
antennas so no two people get the same
station and all of a sudden I realize oh
my God you know after 40 some years of
not even believing in it in two minutes
I turn around and go of course
everything is spiritual
now the meaning of it for me Michael was
so great because you know what happened
fear you had you had a kind of an
instantaneous like Epiphany it just
changed your life the lightning hit me
yeah and and what was interesting within
seconds I lost
fear because I understand that because
the greatest fear people have is death
yes what if you don't die because the
field is always here whether the body
which I call the television
you're watching the Bruce show on the
television set here but the Bruce show
is a broadcast being picked up and
played through the show and I realized
uh you can't die you're not even in here
right where the energy around
here and then but then you know being a
inquisitive scientist I I remember I'll
never forget it I sat there just like oh
my God there's a spirit and there's a
body and a spirit and my science mind
said why not just be a spirit I have a
body and then I found out I had what I
referred to as Jewish comedian cells
because I I asked the question why have
both a body and a spirit and the cells
answered with a question that came right
up in my head and the answer is like
it's so profound and so funny I said why
have a SPID in the body and the and the
cell said Bruce if you're just a spirit
what does chocolate tastes
like now you have to take that one in
for a little bit and realize something
is that
this
body translates energy environments into
pictures and sounds and smells and
feelings uh and all these things and I
go oh my God we came here to experience
life whatever you're waiting for be a
peace of mind contentment Health it will
surely come but only when you're ready
to receive it with openness and
gratitude of all the characteristics
needed for both a happy and morally
decent life none surpasses gratitude
happiness and health are the just
rewards for living in
gratitude wow I remember the first time
I read that I doubted that gratitude
could give me health and happiness but
now I know
differently Igor eigor how sweet of you
to remember my birthday listen let me
blow out the candles make a wish and
then we'll have a party
later ah yes another year would be
wonderful well you know what that whole
story that Ben Franklin told us about
gratitude and health well it actually
works and now scientifically we know why
because built into every one of
ourselves is the Fountain of Youth
what's the Fountain of Youth in the cell
well it's something called tiir tiir
they are special parts of the DNA so
when you open up the nucleus of the cell
the chromosomes come out and they're 46
chromosomes 23 from your mother and 23
from your father but what is a
chromosome well what it is is a sleeve
of protein wrapped around a double helix
of DNA and the significance about this
is the tiir as you can see in this
picture of an X and Y chromosome stained
red are the tiir at the ends of the
chromosome they're the ends of the DNA
are I say so what is the tiir it's
extensions of DNA after the genes
meaning it's a part of the DNA that
doesn't program anything it's just
extended DNA happiness and gratitude now
that's the big one happiness and
gratitude means you love your life so
much that you want more so unconsciously
you will activate the enzyme to increase
and enhance your life this is also
associated with a positive outlook
because if you have a positive Outlook
that means you're looking toward a
future and again feedback says then
we're going to have to activate this
enzyme to have that future and the last
two aspects that enhance the enzyme and
give you long life are very important
and that is again having that self-love
appreciating yourself which means I'm
enjoying and appreciating my life
experience and when you're in love that
of course drives you to stay around even
longer and that will activate the enzyme
and lastly and most importantly is being
in service meaning you have something to
do and what the feedback of the system
is says I can't end now I have to be
here longer I have something to do and
so being in service is one of the most
important things to extend your talir
and keep you around and in conclusion
the information about tiir and tar race
is very important because they represent
the equivalent of a fountain of youth in
every cell and between your mind and
your cells the biology of belief reveals
how your Consciousness and thoughts can
extend your tiir by activating taras
when you appreciate life when you have
gratitude and when you're looking for
love and happiness on the planet you can
extend your life so interesting you're
very powerful to change your life and
make it one of happiness joy and health
for a long long time that's why when I
say on my lectures I say okay how many
people in here have read a self-help
book and all the hands go up I say okay
now how many of you your life changed
after you read the selfhelp book all the
hands go back down I said what's the
issue and the issue is this you educated
your conscious mind the creative mind by
reading a book but the subconscious mind
doesn't learn that way and it's very
important it's resistant to change why
if I learned a habit I don't want it to
change every day if I learned how to
walk I don't want to have to relearn how
to walk all the time I if I learned how
to do it then fine so that basically
says then the subconscious mind is
resistant to change I say number one so
what so what happens how does it do it
like if you're if you're sober years I
have to go back and say well how did you
educate the conscious mind the
subconscious mind in the first place I
go first seven years hypnosis that's
what the brain was in Thea it was just
downloading programs bypassing
Consciousness conscious our conscious
Minds did not filter the download of the
programs and say good program bad
program why conscious mind wasn't
working when the downloads were going so
I just got programs conscious mind
wasn't even there doesn't even have any
idea of it so excuse me the next issue
is this okay your brain is in hypnosis
for first seven years but your
subconscious still learns programs after
you're seven I say how does it learn it
then I go oh
habituation repetition repeat the
behavior over and over and over again
whether that's a healthy Behavior or an
unhealthy Behavior you'll learn a new
pattern depending on what you practice
absolutely because the the the function
of that mind is to take pattern that is
re replayed over and over again and then
acquired that's why look you want to
learn how to drive a car practice drive
a car you want go back this one this a
learning our ABCs go back to your
childhood how long did it take you to
get from A to Z the answer was how many
times did you start a b
c AB b c d
e and then you repeated it you repeated
it you repeated it and finally you got
the Z what was the result I never had to
do it again I habituated it because I
repeated it over and over and over again
that's how I learned how many times did
I repeat the times table in school uh
whatever issue on a job I learn to do
the job I learn how to communicate all
these different things so uh basically
how'd you do that repetition I want what
those people have that are so happy that
every day that happiness brings health
you know it's unhappiness that where the
disease is coming from not from
genes and happiness is our
destination but if you are invisibly
playing a program that means you are the
victim of your program that you don't
even see the damn program but you do see
the outcome of the program and that's
when you start you should be then
alerted to the wakeup call is my life is
my program and if I don't like this I'm
not going to go out and change the life
I first have to go in and change the
program the life will change
automatically after that for some
incredible motivation from Joe despenza
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there the moment you
think differently you're mapping new
Connections in your brain if you keep
thinking differently it's going to feel
uncomfortable in the beginning but nerve
cells that fire together wire together
now you're beginning to create networks
of neurons to reflect